hey everyone i'm john coogan and here's
why you should spend your valuable time
listening to me
talk about startups first i'm an
entrepreneur myself
i've been working on my own startup
since 2012 and i've seen a lot of
different perspectives that i think are
important to share
i've been a co-founder of three
companies i've been a ceo
a cto and a cmo i've served on multiple
boards and have even been an investor
this variety of experience is important
because companies are defined by their
management team
their board of directors and their
shareholders the incentives between
these groups are not always perfectly
aligned
and it's important to understand how
they can diverge if you really want to
know how startups work
i also have experience with companies at
a variety of stages
while my first company only raised
seventeen thousand dollars before
failing a mere five months after
incorporation
my second company soylent raised over 80
million dollars and has been making
money for over seven years now
the decisions faced by a two-person team
going through an incubator
are usually pretty different from those
faced by a series b company expanding
into new markets
my goal is to bring this experience to
bear when analyzing prominent business
case studies
as well as the more fundamental
questions being debated in the startup
community
lastly and more importantly than any
credential or resume bullet
is the fact that i constantly strive to
maintain a balanced view of the world
i love testing counterfactuals and
playing devil's advocate
i never turn down the opportunity to
listen to someone with who i disagree
and i'm always willing to reevaluate a
deeply held position
from first principles i take a very
deliberate approach with my media diet
always trying to find perspectives that
i'm not hearing from and fill them in
there are always two sides to every
story sometimes those sides are equally
reasonable
and sometimes one side is completely
insane but it's still important in my
opinion to understand the other side
my hope is that you will find my
opinions to be well researched
and as objective as possible my goal
with this channel is a little different
than other youtube channels
i'm not trying to grow a large audience
or monetize with ads or sponsorships
i want this channel to be my calling
card in the business world and give you
insight into how i think
the decision to partner with someone in
a business context shouldn't be taken
lightly
often you only have a few hours of real
face-to-face interaction with someone
before deciding to sign documents that
could link you for years
i want anyone who plans on doing
business with me to be able to spend as
much time as they want diligencing my
thought process
since my thought process is ultimately
what you get when you work with me
i also want to connect with the next
generation of entrepreneurs who may be
searching youtube for ways to solve a
hard problem that they're facing
i want to be able to find and invest in
the best startups out there and the next
generation of great entrepreneurs
are watching youtube right now so if
you're building something cool
please reach out to me i really hope you
enjoy my content and consider
subscribing to the channel to get
updates i try and post new videos weekly
and i'm always reading the comments
thanks for watching this video and
subscribing to the channel